l'union européenne à l'épreuve du
coronavirus la violence du choc
économique engendrée par l'épidémie aura
valeur de test pour la cohésion de la
zone euro elle cette crise met déjà en
lumière l'absence de solidarité entre
certains états membres
elle signe aussi l'abandon de règles
budgétaires qui hier encore sembler
fondamentale l union européenne est
telle qu'on la connaît aujourd'hui
peut-elle survivre un tel défi on voit
cela a tout de suite avec notre
économiste jacques saint-pierre bonjour
jacques bienvenu merci d'être avec nous
deux chez vous un confinement oblige
jacques que ce passe-t-il aussi aux
justes au sein de l'union européenne
bien pierre il est clair que la crise du
couronne un virus est un défi immense un
défi majeur pour l'union européenne
l'absence de solidarité est aujourd'hui
une évidence entre les pays de l'union
européenne depuis le début de la crise
en réalité c'est le chacun pour soi
au point que l'italie reçoit aujourd'hui
de l'est de la russie de la chine de
cuba même beaucoup plus que d autres
pays de l'union européenne alors
signalons d'ailleurs qu'une partie des
masques de protection envoyé par la
chine à l'italie ont été en réalité
voler ou accaparés par le gouvernement
tchèque à l'occasion d'une escale de
l'avion qui les a menés en italie alors
au delà de ce triste épisode
cet incident est néanmoins très
révélateur d'une absence complète de
solidarité entre les pays de l'union
européenne comme l'écrivait hier
l'ancien premier ministre belge guy
verhofstadt qui a fait un papier qui est
extrêmement critique sur le mode de
fonctionnement de l'union européenne
pour revenir un petit peu au
commencement jacques
comment est-ce que l'union européenne a
réagi cette crise sanitaire
alors il faut savoir que dans l'union
européenne
il existe normalement est mécanique de
protection civile qui est censé
coordonner les actions des différents
pays membres l'italie le 26 février et
l'espagne le 16 mars ont demandé par
l'intermédiaire justement de ce fameux
mécanisme de protection civile de
l'union européenne
du matériel de protection
supplémentaires en particulier des
masques médicaux et des respirateurs ces
demandes sont restées sans réponse et ça
ça pose déjà un problème énorme
c'est ce qui a contraint d'ailleurs
l'italie de se tourner vers d'autres
pays mais mais il ya bien eu une
réaction
alors oui bien sûr il ya eu une réaction
mais vous voyez ce n'est que le 19 mars
autrement dit 22 jours après la première
demande que la commission européenne a
décidé de créer une réserve sous le nom
de alors excusez-moi pour l'acronyme
resque vu la réserve européenne commune
qui concerne le matériel médical
d'urgence telles que des respirateurs
des masques de protection et du petit
matériel de laboratoire afin d'aider les
pays de l'union européenne qui sont dans
le besoin
seulement 13 heures se heurte
actuellement aux politiques des
différents états un membre de mieux qui
veulent garder pour eux ce matériel mais
comment vous l'expliquez saint jacques
alors il faut comprendre qu'il ya
d'abord des facteurs objectifs tous les
pays de l'union européenne n'ont pas été
touchés en même temps et avec la même
gravité la gravité de l'épidémie est
différente suivant les pays ce qui veut
dire que le sentiment d'urgence et on le
voit en particulier sur ce graphique
le sentiment d'urgence n'a pas été le
même suivant les pays ajoutons que les
stratégies suivies par les différents
pays diffère aussi largement dépistage
de masse en allemagne vous savez on a
parlé des 70000 test par jour qui sont
réalisées en allemagne contre 9000 en
france le fait que certains pays veulent
appliquer la fameuse théorie de
l'immunité collective
c'est le cas de la suède et des pays bas
bref il n'y a pas eu de stratégie
commune
est ce qu'on peut parler de déchets
qu'un de l'union européenne et comment
l'union européenne at-elle réagi sur le
plan économique
alors tout d'abord oui c'est un camp
c'est incontestablement un échec
après cet échec qui révèle d'ailleurs le
manque de solidarité entre les pays de
l'union européenne
il se porte aussi sur la question
économique reprenons un petit peu la
chronologie le 6 mars l'union européenne
accorde une aide temporaire et sous
conditions à l'italie le 13 mars
elle commence à envisager des aides
ciblées mais qui sont largement
inférieurs à ceux dont les pays de
l'union européenne
italie france allemagne espagne ont
besoin enfin le 23 mars la retournement
de situation nous avons la déclaration
des ministres des finances qui décide
d'abandonner la fameuse rhein de
stabilité budgétaire vous savez les
critères de maastricht
autrement dit c'est la mort de
l'objectif de 3% du déficit message à
que c'est plutôt une bonne mesure non
oui évidemment
seulement ce que l'on voit c'est que
l'union européenne a toujours été en
retard d'un train pendant près de deux
semaines
de fait ce sont les gouvernements des
différents pays qui ont été contraints
de prendre des mesures exceptionnelles
ces mesures exceptionnelles dont on
avait parlé la semaine dernière dans
cette émission donc l'union européenne
qu'est ce qu'elle fait en réalité balle
entérine la politique des états est
autrement dit elle a implicitement
reconnu que les gouvernements nationaux
étaient les mieux placées pour gérer la
situation et ça c'est un énorme aveu
d'échec
mais si la commission est dépassée la
banque centrale européenne ne peut-elle
pas agir alors oui effectivement
la banque centrale européenne aurait pu
reprendre la main sauf que christine
lagarde sa présidente a loupé sa
conférence de presse du 6 mars il faut
bien le dire en laissant entendre que
les taux de la dette souveraine
italienne et des passants à faire et
cela a eu des conséquences
regardez les les taux italiens sur les
bons du trésor à 10 ans ils ont
brutalement
monte alors évidemment la déclaration
malencontreuse de christine lagarde qui
avait provoqué cette forte tension sur
les taux a immédiatement appelé appelé
des réactions madame lagarde a corrigé
le tir
elle a décidé d'abord d'un plan de 750
milliards d'euros dead mais il était
déjà un petit peu trop tard alors la bce
aujourd'hui et ça c'est si vous les
rangs en fait ils n'ont fait dans la
nuit les textes n'ont été publiés que ce
matin donc aujourd'hui la bce a décidé
d'un plan d'urgence
le pe pp alors excusez moi ça veut dire
le pandémique est maintenant ses
puncheurs zing programme
qu'est ce que ça veut dire ça veut dire
que c'est un programme d'achat des bons
du trésor des différents états sans
limitation de volume
j'insiste là dessus sans limitation de
volume et ça c'est un grand retournement
par rapport à la doctrine de l'union
européenne et n'est ce pas particulier à
l'italie alors en réalité non parce que
si on regarde la courbe du bon du trésor
à 10 ans français
bien sûr il va rester avec niveau plus
humain observe à peu près le même
mouvement
une baisse régulière jusqu'au 6 mars
et puis aussi mars il ya justement cette
espèce de piques brutale en réalité il
faut comprendre que les taux d'intérêt
qui aujourd'hui sont en train de se
calmer mais qui sont quand même à un
niveau supérieur au niveau qu'ils
avaient au début de mois de janvier
eh bien les taux d'intérêt pourrait
repartir à la hausse dès que l'on
mesurera à quel point ces pays devront
s'endetter vous savez que on parle de
déficit budgétaire de six huit voire de
10% à la suite de la crise et dès que
l'on mesurera l'ampleur de la récession
avec des valeurs du produit intérieur
brut qui vont reculer de 3 à 5% au
minimum sur l'année mais que va-t-il se
passer alors jacques ça c'est une bonne
question
la zone euro va connaître et c'est
évident une nouvelle crise alors bien
sûr nous avons le pe bp qui autorise ces
rachats illimité d'actions publiques
mais ce programme il faut le savoir est
très vulnérable
il pourrait être en particulier
contester légalement devant la cour de
justice de l'union européenne par
différents pays
on pense à l'allemagne évidemment qui
est très opposée à ce genre de méthodes
aux pays-bas ou à la finlande
nous avons aussi la discussion autour de
la création des eurobonds ou en tous les
cas de bons du trésor qu'ils seraient
liées justement à cet ebit hymne à cette
épidémie selon il faut savoir que les
eurobonds on en parle depuis 2011
et à chaque fois l'allemagne les pays
bas et la finlande se sont opposées se
sont refusés à cette création
alors le constat c'est que l'union
européenne aujourd'hui ne fait plus
rêver il faudra penser très certainement
à des revirements déchirant et on voit
bien que c'est toute la construction
européenne de l'union européenne à
l'euro qui est aujourd'hui durablement
ébranlée par la crise un dernier exemple
angela merkel qui a fait une longue
déclaration où il ya quelques jours n'a
même pas évoqué une fois l'union
européenne
dans cette déclaration et on voit que
même à bruxelles
bien des responsables lui croit plus eh
bien merci beaucoup jacques sapir pour
toutes ces précisions très éclairantes
mais pas forcément un très très
optimiste
à très bientôt jacques sapir sur arte
france